[Musica]
permettetemi di iniziare con una piccola
storia personale
sono cresciuto a rieti qui ho fatto le
elementari e le medie poi a 14 anni ho
avuto la fortuna di passare due anni in
california
quindi ho fatto il primo e secondo
riceve in california e immaginate un
ragazzino di 14 anni tipica high school
americana
la classe di biologia un certo punto
durante il corso cioè il science project
un classico lì si chiede ai ragazzi di
formare un team e poi di ideare un
progetto sul quale lavorare perfetto
sembra una cosa banale magari a voi
adesso ma per me in quel momento era
estremamente entusiasmante era stato
abituato semplicemente a scuola ad avere
i compiti da portare a casa a studiare
fare i compiti portarli la mattina dopo
al professore per un bel voto
e invece questa volta dovevo fare un
team dovevo ideare un progetto era tutto
un mondo nuovo per me il team fu facile
mai che il mio compagno di banco sarebbe
stato alla piena e metà del film
il progetto invece fu più interessante
io in modo molto innocente pensai forse
un buon modo di fare il progetto di
biologia intervistare qualcuno che di
biologia ne capisce un po più di me e
quindi presi le pagine gialle era all 88
un po di tempo fa e cercai la stanford
university perché io vivevo
relativamente vicino a stanford comunque
un'università estremamente prestigiosa
trovai il dipartimento di biologia il
numero di philippe lana walt professore
mi sembra a capo proprio del
dipartimento di biologia
io con molta nonchalance chiamai parlai
con la assistente gentilissima che mi
passò subito il professore che sia
professore un'intervista e lui me l'ha
concesse a me a mike quindi qualche
giorno dopo eravamo davanti al
professore nel suo ufficio a
intervistarlo a fare domande che per lui
probabilmente erano del tipo quanto fa
uno più uno per la loro banalità eppure
io e mike e ci sentivamo dei
professionisti estremamente grandi ormai
già a fare quella cosa
uscimmo infatti estremamente soddisfatti
fieri come se avessimo già raggiunto un
traguardo incredibile della nostra vita
e con la testa alta andammo dalla mamma
che ci aspettava il parcheggio per
portarci a casa
mi chiesi in realtà mai perché il
professor ana volta accetta
un'intervista con due ragazzini
quattordicenni oggi apprezzo la sua
umiltà e la sua curiosità per poterci
concedere quell'ora che per noi
probabilmente ha cambiato la vita ma
soprattutto che ha insegnato a meno a me
una lezione importante
torna in italia dopo quei due anni poi
continuare gli studi in italia di nuovo
in america per l'università ma anche in
francia ea singapore ho avuto la fortuna
di essere esposto a tanti sistemi
scolastici ea diverse materie una cosa
che però continuamente continuavo a
chiedermi anzi due dubbi che avevo erano
uno tutto quello che studiavo mi
sembrava comunque nozionistico e non
applicabile poi a qualcosa di concreto
el altra cosa e che comunque anche
assorbendo tante nuove conoscenze a me
questa cosa non mi tornava nella
aiutarmi a vivere poi comunque la vita
reale meglio e quindi sentivo non lo so
è come se mi avessero consegnato dei
manuali di istruzioni ricchi
dettagliatissimi perfetti ma per
elettrodomestici o che non avevo poche
neanche sapevo a cosa servissero insomma
sentivo una grande incoerenza tra la
scuola e la vita vera in sostanza lo
continuato a sentire per un bel po fino
a un certo punto quando ha avuto un
segnale invece è interessante quando
sono entrato in una business school e
internazionale e dove si ci si
focalizzava molto sul concetto di fare
network tra le persone e fare rete con
gli studenti e con i professori questo
era già un messaggio diverso io da
trentenne bello giovane ancora con i
capelli con i ricci sia una storia vera
iniziali di nuovo molto appassionato
dicendo studierò tantissimo sui libri e
anche questo anno andrà benissimo
e invece fu diverso perché dal primo
momento dal primo giorno mi assegnarono
un team continua internazionale appunto
una scuola internazionale
io ero l'italiano c'era un americano un
francese un brasiliano un indiano e un
cinese sembra una barzelletta ma è vero
e tutto il lavoro che avremmo fatto per
i seguenti quattro mesi
lavoro di gruppo non avremmo mai
ricevuto un voto singolo ma i voti erano
sempre per il gruppo per il team è come
se per la prima volta avessero detto
ragazzi adesso hanno giocato è più sport
singoli ma solo sport di squadra
interessante per la prima volta il
concetto di fare network ed era
diventato per me parte integrante di un
sistema scolastico e questa era
estremamente interessante adesso io
all'inizio in realtà ero sospettoso
l'idea di fare rete tra le persone mi
sembrava quasi un concetto sporco come
se sfruttarsi gli altri per ottenerne un
beneficio qualcosa di poco etico e forse
perché ero cresciuto nella scuola
classica nella quale per rendere per
performare devi prendere voti a te in
genere tuoi voti di paragoni sempre agli
altri studenti che quindi diventano
quasi competizione invece che colleghi
reali eppure questa volta il fatto di
giocare intima a me piaceva e quindi mi
appassionai molto quell'anno alla fine
dell'anno ebbe l'onore di parlare a
tutta la classe il giorno del diploma
quindi un paio di migliaia di persone
considerando anche le famiglie e il
messaggio per me era chiaro nella vita
mi raccomando bisogna fare network
bisogna lavorare insieme insomma in un
certo senso pensavo già ad aver capito
tutto di cosa la scuola doveva insegnare
a fare fare network però era solamente
un primo segnale in futuro poi ho
cominciato a insegnare all'università in
italia e io insegno all'università di
tra i 18 ei 23 anni nel settore del
digitale che quello che mi compete
perché lavora in questo settore
è però interessante perché nel settore
del digitale io ormai sono relativamente
vecchio anche se ricordo bene magari non
lo so però i ragazzi giovani hanno in
realtà il polso della situazione io io
tante volte a inizio del corso
facevo dei piccoli sondaggi per capire
ad esempio il social network preferito e
così ho visto proprio il passaggio da
facebook a instagram a tik tok at which
eccetera insomma per ogni lezione che io
concedeva loro loro gratuitamente me ne
restituivano ora è questo aggiungeva
interesse al mio a questa idea di fare
network e fare rete
e collaborare con con i ragazzi in
questo caso studenti poi l'illuminazione
a un certo punto è arrivata in realtà
proprio qui a rieti
grazie a un programma filantropico che
insieme a ex compagni liceali abbiamo
fondato qua proprio circa undici anni fa
e questo programma l'abbiamo creato per
passare due valori alle nuove
generazioni ai ragazzi la voglia di fare
e l'ottimismo e lo facciamo
semplicemente chiedendo ai ragazzi quali
sono dei loro sogni dei progetti sui
quali vogliono lavorare e li mettiamo in
contatto con adulti che spesso sono in
realtà ex studenti della stessa scuola e
collaborando lavorano un progetto che
nel giro magari di un paio d'anni questi
sogno realizzato richiamiamo un poco si
portano fino all'esecuzione o comunque
ci prova questo fu molto interessante
perché durante questi undici anni ormai
sono undici anni ho ricevuto tantissimi
segnali che hanno confermato questa idea
che di fare network fare rete fosse così
importante ricordo ancora una delle
prime partecipanti caterina che si
inventò una radio online il proprio
liceo mi disse che l'esperienza in
questo programma filantropico era
diventata una delle pietre miliari del
suo percorso liceale e già questo per me
araba senza sensazionale un altro tipo
di messaggio mi arriva invece dai
volontari dagli adulti che forse ancora
più ad alto impatto uno dei tanti mento
era una volta mi disse sai che alle
volte penso che i ragazzi mi stiano
insegnando più di quanto io insegni loro
ecco allora mettendo tutto insieme ho
cominciato a rendermi conto che questa
idea che forse all'inizio che pensavo un
po sporca e poco etica del fare network
del fare rete del collaborare
indipendentemente dall'età potesse
veramente funzionare rendere anche il
sistema scolastico migliore ora se da
una parte è chiaro per me che il fare
rete è di primaria importanza nella
nostra società poi praticamente però
come si fa secondo me ci sono due
ingredienti fondamentali che vanno
sottolineati per capire se poi si può si
può portare avanti un'idea come questo
sia un atteggiamento alla
il tan bisogna insegnare l'umiltà a cui
potersi confrontare con chiunque sapendo
che da questa persona si può apprendere
un vecchio lo può fare confrontandosi
con un giovane e viceversa
e una un atteggiamento continuo alla
curiosità e la curiosità può essere
educata e può essere esercitata
praticata se uno questi due ingredienti
li mette dentro probabilmente qualcosa
può scappare il professore ana walt di
stanford
in realtà era stato estremamente
generoso ma anche umile nel voler
conoscere due ragazzi quattordicenni e
curiosa in un certo senso di capire su
cosa volessimo lavorare
ora mi rendo conto che lui a me ha
probabilmente dato un segnale che mi ha
cambiato la vita
ma oggi giorno nella nostra realtà se ci
pensate un attimo pensate a dai due
punti di vista noi adulti noi grandi
quanto spesso diamo un'opportunità a un
ragazzo e una ragazza di 20 o 30 anni
più giovane di noi quando magari queste
persone questi ragazzi giovani vogliono
parlare con noi per discutere di un
qualunque idea o progetto dedichiamo
un'ora del nostro prezioso tempo a
questi ragazzi e ragazze
dall'altro lato voi ragazzi e ragazze
molto giovani avete avete il coraggio
l'intraprendenza e vi sentireste a
vostro agio a chiamare un qualunque
professionista di qualunque età
parlando di una vostra idea e un basso
progetto fare network in una società
dovrebbe essere naturale noi siamo
animali estremamente sociali
eppure la scuola un po pecca nel non
educarci a fare rete soprattutto in modo
inter inter generazionale e allora io
insisto su questo punto per migliorare
il sistema scolastico probabilmente in
qualche modo si dovrebbe stimolare
questa collaborazione tra generazioni
diverse e quindi cercando ad esempio di
attivare programmi e attività che
permettono ai ragazzi delle scuole di
interfacciarsi in qualche modo con i
grandi con il mondo esterno la scuola
progetti attività
eventi l'importante è che si facciano
insieme lo fa oggi la scuola sicuramente
qualcosa fa ad esempio nello sport si
sente qualcosa è secondo me molto
importante però c'è sicuramente molto
molto altro che può essere fatto e
allora
detto questo siccome di scuola si parla
io vi darei proprio un compito in classe
se avete voglia e il compito che spero
proverete a fare quando lasciate questo
fantasticamente dx è quello di provare a
fare rete ma provate a fare rete con
qualcuno che non conoscete e che magari
idealmente di una generazione totalmente
diversa dalla vostra e partite date il
benvenuto un pensiero dentro di voi
posso imparare qualcosa da questa
persona indipendentemente dall'età e lo
dico sì ai giovani e ai vecchi ai grandi
tra virgolette e se date benvenuto a
questo pensiero poi cercate di stimolare
la vostra curiosità cosa è praticamente
che questa persona potrebbe insegnarmi
in base alle sue esperienze specifiche
sicuramente su questo ci scommetto
ognuno ogni essere umano può insegnare
qualcosa un altro essere umano
e allora stimolate questa cosa magari
non succederà nulla
e magari invece da quel momento inizierà
un dialogo e chissà che questo fra dieci
o quindici anni potrà diventare un altro
progetto magari filantropico per la
comunità
una società che sa fare rete tra le
generazioni secondo me a società
migliore è una società che si aiuta che
si che si stimola e che si rinnova
soprattutto se riusciamo a passare il
testimone alle nuove generazioni
e allora cerchiamo di creare una società
dove un mentor dei ragazzi di questo del
programma filantropico magari impara a
lavorare meglio osservando come i
ragazzi lavorano a scuola in team
creiamo una società dove un professore
di un'università come la stanford dedica
un'ora del proprio tempo a due ragazzini
di 14 anni delle loro progetto di
scienza diamo l'opportunità a ragazzi
che hanno forse la media di 18 19 anni
di organizzare eventi come questo
stupendo takes
di oggi se facciamo queste cose è
possibile che ci ritroveremo in una
società molto più attiva virtuosa e
probabilmente dove i legami tra le
persone saranno anche legami più di
sostanza potrebbero essere semplicemente
collaborazioni che potrebbe diventare
amicizie o anche qualcosa in più ecco io
mi auguro che questo sia il messaggio
che passi e dei compiti a casa proviate
a farli tutti quanti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]